germany is preparing to host leaders
from the group of seven wealthy
countries at a summit that opens in
bavaria on sunday
securities tight as thousands of
protesters gather in the state capital
munich and a town near the summit venue
to make their voices heard activists are
set to join marches planned by
greenpeace oxfam and numerous other
non-governmental organizations they're
calling on g7 leaders to take a greater
action against climate change and global
poverty
and we're joined now by dw correspondent
julia sodelli at the terresian visa in
munich where munich's famous oktoberfest
usually takes place today however it is
the setting for a big anti-g7 protest
julia police warned that the
demonstration there in munich could end
up in chaos how tense is the situation
if at all
it is quite relaxed right now people are
still arriving and the visa this area
here is slowly filling up
there's a lot of different people young
people older people and it's quite an
interesting mix of organizations that
are taking part here but until now it's
been very peaceful people are giving
speeches playing music and there's not
really much tension although there is
quite a strong police presence all
around the perimeter here of the field
where uh the the reunion of the
demonstrators is taking place and there
is a lot of police presence all around
the center of munich so the police is
ready in case of the situation where uh
to to change and become less peaceful
and less relaxed
now the the summit gets underway on
sunday but some world leaders are
expected to arrive today already you say
there's a huge police presence how are
the preparations going
they're here in munich there's obviously
police ready to act in case of the
protest today but the actual g7 summit
is taking place around 100 kilometers
from here near a town called gamish
patencian and the police presence there
is also very heavy there are blocks on
the road to try to get there helicopters
flying so the preparations are ongoing
people are starting to arrive and
the summit itself will kick off
tomorrow and that's when the leaders
will come together and begin meeting in
this castle in the bavarian alps a very
exclusive and beautiful location
now just very briefly julia are those
protesters expected to also move to
garmisch-partenkirchen to that location
or will they stay put in munich
there are already some protesters that
are there in gamish patency they have
started building up a camp where they
expect to camp out for the next few days
during the summit and there are protests
already organized for the days to come
they're in gamespat in kitchen and there
a lot of people that are now in munich
will also move to the town there to take
part in the protests there
all right uh julia sodelli they're
reporting for us from the theresa music
munich thank you so much
and we're joined now by luisa noibauer
she is one of the founders of germany's
friday for future climate movement and
she joins me online from berlin now
welcome to the program good to have you
with us
so
good morning before we talk about the g7
summit uh let's take a look at the
broader situation because much of europe
of course is now trying to break free
from its dependence on russian oil and
gas
the german economy minister who himself
is a member of the green party
decided to reactivate coal-fired power
plants
can you sympathize with his dilemma
well it's not his dilemma technically
it's a dilemma that you know societies
everywhere are in and especially the the
german society as we're just so
dependent on russian
gas and oil
and yes there are big questions now how
to fill the gaps um in the in the energy
systems but there's just this huge
difference between filling and gaps and
creating new lengthy long lasting
dependency on fossil fuels and their
autocrats and when you know ministers
say okay you know for now we have to
jiggle around a bit and fill it with
with some coal that might be fair enough
as long as climate demands are still met
as long as we're still sticking to a co2
budget meaning maybe you know
having an earlier collective than
planned um you know fiddling in um to to
fit in with our climate um budget right
in the long run
do you have any ideas uh any
alternatives that you could suggest
instead of reactivating coal-fired
plants so is this basically the only
solution we have right now
um i am not an energy systems expert and
um they have opinions though on what um
they are saying in germany is that for
now on for for this year and especially
for the next winter yes it is crucial
that we fill in our gas tanks and that
means for instance for a short amount of
time having more coal but
it must not mean that we open up for
instance numerous new installed lng
terminals on the german coast that we do
new drillings and that we create all
these new dependencies that drive us
even further down the road of climate
catastrophe i mean 2022 it should be
that turning point it should be that
moment where leaders everywhere decide
to turn away from fossil fuels as it
sparks climate disasters and wars it
should be the time where we look at
renewables and understand they're at
hand they are there they're ready to be
installed as soon as the political will
is there right i mean it must be very
frustrating because for many years the
friday for futures movement was gaining
momentum then came the pandemic and now
the war in ukraine this upcoming g7
summit was supposed to focus on climate
change now the focus is understandably
on ukraine do you have a feeling that uh
political leaders have completely lost
sight of the climate emergency
um honestly i don't know what political
leaders um you know are looking at and
what not but what it seems like from the
outside is that obviously many of them
don't want to or cannot understand the
emergency we are in and that there is um
you know that things are connected that
a war
fueled and and financed by fossil fuels
is part of the of the big spiral of
fossil fuel destruction that is causing
wars that is causing you know um yeah
the destruction of our livelihoods and
so reacting to fossil fuel rule with
more fossil fuels it just doesn't make
sense even on geopolitical level so for
the sake of the world we inherited that
is there for us to save the future that
is you know in in the hands of the
leaders right now and in our certainly
we must stop playing out these crises
against each other and understanding
that they're dots that should be
connected
uh last question final question because
obviously we mentioned that there are uh
protests uh preparing anyway to go ahead
uh what concrete decisions do you and
the protesters want to see at the g7
yeah that's a really good question so
first of all this summit must be a turn
away from fossil fuels this means
sticking to the agreements that have
already been made and namely ending
foreign funding for fossil fuels which
olaf schultz is about to crack down
which would be devastating it must
include
committing to a coal exit in 2030 which
g7 leaders must decide on the summit and
of course it must include actually you
know consequent and honest commitments
for loss and damage financing the global
south and of course talking about ending
the depths of the global source to
actually yeah make
proper and honest collaboration on a
global level possible
luis and neubauer one of the founders of
germany friday's the future climate
movement thank you so very much
thank you
well for germany the summit will mark
the high point of its turn at the helm
of the rotating g7 presidency the group
includes the most advanced economies
that's the united states canada the
united kingdom france germany italy and
japan
they're home to 10 of the world's
population but they account for a third
of global economic output germany holds
the rotating presidency of the group and
this meeting will be dominated by a
daunting set of crises with russia's war
in ukraine and climate change topping
the agenda but as dw's richard walker
reports these issues are nothing new for
the g7
germany's baltic sea coast 2007
angela merkel hosting one of the first
major summits of her career as
chancellor its name the g8
that's right back then it was still the
g8 a group of seven rich liberal
democracies plus russia also on board
vladimir putin was there and some of the
photos even made it look quite friendly
seen from today it looks like a parallel
universe
and yet all was not well
putin was angry about u.s plans for a
missile defense system
just a year later he would invade
georgia
other challenges were mounting too the
g8 promised to tackle climate change or
at least it sort of did in this final
declaration it promised to consider
cutting emissions by half by 2050
fast forward to 2015 and this time
merkel hosted in the mountains
the g8 was now the g7 again putin was
gone the group threw him out over the
annexation of crimea
this became the signature image it
suggested a meeting of minds in a group
now coming closer together without the
russians around
and yet russia loomed over things as the
final declaration made clear
it condemned the annexation of crimea
and said that russia must respect
ukraine's sovereignty
and there was a growing sense of time
running out on climate change with calls
for urgent and concrete action
fast forward again to today and russia's
war in ukraine will totally dominate
this year's summit
a war destabilizing europe and
potentially the whole world
the g7 will try to underscore western
unity in the face of all of this
and it will also try to tackle some of
the fallout of the war
like the food crisis and the energy
crunch
and with forest fires already hitting
near berlin this year the climate crisis
will be back on the agenda again
the new german chancellor olaf schultz
will use his debut as host to push a
plan called the climate club that he
says could make a difference
so looking back again at those photos
from 2007
they may seem like they're from a
parallel universe
but when you think about it the
challenges of then have become the
crisis of now
we'll have to see if schultz and his
fellow g7 leaders can do anything
meaningful about them
you